j'ai gelé clé ce soir ici d'accord vous
avez effectivement j'ai cette page 19
les épreuves 19le l'agent immobilier
avait oublié mais bon vu que la
connaissance d'une connaissance c'était
pas menti vous n'étiez pas au courant
que la maison était squatté oui bernard
alors ça c'est faux vous savez quand
vous achetez une maison il ya un acte
notarié pardon hein il ya un pardon
monsieur mais en tout cas c'est la
réalité ce que je dis est un acte
notarié on vous donne les clés soc a été
précisée dans l'acte de vente a pas que
vous taisez tu me cites justice et
justice mais bon là c'est les notaires
c'est un peu différent mais là c'était
marqué sur l'acte de vente étaient
marqués occupation sans droit ni titre
pourquoi parce qu'ils savaient et
monsieur savais que quelqu'un était
dedans ce n'est pas le nier ça c'est non
ces jeux qu'on peut nier passer
d'ajustements bcia alors jacques de
vente sous les huées ça ne donne pas
alors réalisé à lille va en parler bon
déjà une idée c'est de bien rappeler que
même que laurent c'est la victime parce
que là depuis 48 heures on lit sur les
réseaux sociaux on va des articles
d'impression effectivement qu'il a roulé
tout le monde faut bien comprendre que
le vendeur il a encaissé son argent
l'agent mobilier après sa commission ce
qui est normal l'endettement n'est en
rien ce qu'on reproche à la laurent je
vous dire la vérité c'est que la maison
il a acheté en connaissant ce vraiment
un prix très très très bas par rapport
au marché et qu'en fait on se dit il
savait qu'elle était squatté il a dit
bah tant pis je prends le risque je vais
payer beaucoup moins cher cette maison
après je vais me démerder peut porter de
faire sortir les squatteurs et voilà
mais qu'il le savait avant on défend pas
du tout les squatteurs rien du tout on
vous sur l'auvent voilà ils aillent
habiter dans sa maison parce qu'il a
aidé à payer sept ans les tenants et les
aboutissants c'est qu'on se dit il
savaient que la maison était beaucoup
moins cher donc il savait qu'il y avait
un problème c'est vrai que c'est bizarre
quand une maison dans le même quartier
dans la même rue il y en a une qui vaut
cent quarante mille et l'autre à côté
elle en est elle à 180 c'est la même
logique un moment tu dis un problème et
le problème du nexus s et c'est
peut-être ça oui j l'on voit un vélo on
va nous répondre oui laurent
effectivement votre histoire de clé là
ça tombe comme par miracle mais dans la
vidéo avec l'agent immobilier une dame
on voit très bien qu'elle dit il n'y a
pas eu de remise de clés il faudra
maintenant faire partir les gens qui
sont là bas est votre recette vidéo elle
ne date pas d'hier elle date de très
longtemps et quand vous allez devant la
maison pour les médias avec un trousseau
de terre de renvoyer je peux pas rentrer
ce sont des fausses clés vous le savez
laurent vous ne pouvez pas nier ça la
halle à ce jour là effectivement j'avais
plus j'avais pas les clés avec moi ils
m'ont demandé de prendre un trousseau de
clés de faire comme si c'étaient les
clés de sa pour reconnaissez la mise en
scène et mensonges à basile et ils m'ont
demandé de faire ça je il vendrait entre
le média vous l'avez le parisien le
premier article dans le parisien je
c'est écrit noir sur blanc lors de la
promesse de vente effectivement c'était
écrit avec un occupant sans droit ni
titre et ça j'ai l'acte final de veulent
de la vente il est ici c'est marquer
alors la place finale on l'a on a là la
première vente indique effectivement
cette précision le lui si je passe au
gouverneur dont l'acte de vente précise
bien donc ça c'est l'argument du 19 mai
donc c'est la vente définitive c'est
important parce qu'on lui reproche le 19
mai d'être parti dans cette maison et de
d'avoir feint la surprise alors c'est
pas le cas puisque c'est bien indiqué
que le bien est entièrement libre de
location ou occupations non je parle
sous le contrôle de la lors de la
promesse de vente laurent ni colorant
savais qu'il y avait un matelas dans la
maison et qu'elle était souvent occupé
ce que vous aviez dit
elle est souvent occupé il ya des gens
qui paraissent aller vous pensez qu'ils
avaient des relents qui passe et david
david bowman experts en immobilier que
ce qu'on pensait de cette affaire
normalement j'ai un peu d'empathie pour
les gens qui se sentent lésés avec un
avec un grand b mais là je dois avouer
que j'en ai pas parce que c'est pas
possible ça veut dire je dis pas que
vous mentez parce que moi je vous
connais pas enfin voila je dis pas que
vous mentez mais c'est impossible
d'acheter un bien deux fois moins cher
que le prix du marché est passé chez un
notaire le notaire il est une obligation
il est une obligation de vous dire ce
bien là il ya un truc c'est pas possible
qui coûte ce prix là le lac de vente que
vous avez montré parfait mais il peut
avoir des avenants donc il nous faut
tous le compromis moi je vous dis
j'étais avec ma femme quand on regardait
la télé elle est à deux doigts de faire
une cagnotte city moi je lui ai dit
écoute
des litchis
j'ai dit et non brouille parce que tu
peux pas acheter un bien 140000 euros ou
2 et à un bien qui vaut trois cent mille
euros lâcheté 140000 euros et que le
notaire ne disent rien c'est impossible
et donc moi je dois avouer que j'ai du
mal
à croire à cette version est encore une
fois peut-être qu'on va s'apercevoir
demain que le notaire n'a pas bien fait
son travail etc mais franchement j'y
crois pas et même vous vous avez l'air
bien intelligent etc vous pouvez pas
acheter un bien deux fois moins cher
sans savoir qui est un problème et sa
chute dans les affaires en immobilier
sas est très souvent acheter des biens
squatter ça se fait c'est c'est un
business model c'est à dire qu' il ya
des gens dont c'est le travail qui font
que ça ils achètent des biens squatté et
ils ont une équipe de juristes et il
s'occupe de le porter ça veut dire de
payer le crédit en attendant que les
squatteurs parts et
parce que davie dans l'appareil
j'apprécie dit que le notaire et les
agences immobilières ou refuser notre
invitation ce soir donc voilà raymond
après c'est intéressant l'histoire d'une
réponse à savoir que le notaire lui
touche une commission n'a dessus sur le
prix de la maison sont m'intéresse c'est
pas de la brader le notaire sont
intéressés de la revendre au prix du
marché pour qui touche lui sa commission
sur trois cent mille euros pas sûr
140000 si elle va les 300000 euros mois
ou rouge tu en veux laurent je vais te
parler franchement c'est que tu nous a
pas dit quand tu es venu que tu avais
pas les clés et tu savais très bien
qu'ils avaient des squatteurs dessus et
nous tout le plateau même toute la
france on a eu de l'empathie pour toi et
ta fiancée on a voulu vous sauver on a
voulu faire des trucs
en fait au final on se rend compte que
tu savais c'est tout pareil cette
cession est une merguez non mais bon c
est pas fait pour être grossier il nous
a pris pour des cons tout nous la france
entière et nous a pris pour des cons en
vérité pas pouvait dire non moi moi j'ai
l'impression que non mais
franchement quand j'ai vu la vidéo avec
la avec la zai médias qui fait hélas on
n'a pas donné les clés parce que
maintenant faudra center benghazi dit
mme aubry
répond à ça on va l'essayer et laurent
raconte là on a l'impression que les
secours et continuera sa loge donc là
vous êtes en train de dire que la maison
là dans cet état là donc à vos trois
cent mille euros
j'ai dit que si au nombre de mètres
carrés par rapport à la rue tu la payes
deux fois moins cher ce s'est créé un
loup mais c'est parce que c'est pas deux
fois moins cher en fait ils appellent
concrètement par rapport aux revenus
marché cent mille euros de moins il ya
deux raisons à ça parce que ce soit
45 cents à 40 mais le 240 à verser une
maison qui a effectivement été été
squattés visiter qui est complètement
délabré dedans il ya tout à refaire et
tu sais bien david puisque je connais un
petit peu déjà lorsqu'on achète une
maison qui est complètement ravagé où
rien ne tient ses parents goût il ya
quatre murs sur un jardin ça dont il ya
énormément de travaux énormes
deuxièmement pour répondre à l'histoire
du squat qu'on comprenne bien fait
contents ils sont partis visiter que sa
compagne l'appartement la maison au mode
de septembre avec un agent immobilier
qui leur a dit voilà tu en entends
l'appartement la maison est squatté
d'ailleurs il ya un matelas il n'a
jamais nié mais il ya une différence
entre ceux d'hier l'appartement
exploiter temps en temps par sdf qui
passe ou par des jeunes qui font la fête
avec juste un matelas d'ailleurs et se
rendent compte le journal catholique ces
jeux famille est installée chien avec
les leurs portails changer un abonnement
téléphonique edf avec cinq enfants ce
n'est pas la même chose lorsqu'ils ont
découvert le 19 mai c était squatté la
surprise a été réelle parce qu'il
pensait un squat qui n'a pas manqué son
mondial où il n'a pas menti mais pas
mais pas le résultat alors
on a l'impression que vous réécrivez
l'histoire et n'ont jamais l'histoire de
cette maison cette maison aurait été
jean-paul conditionnelle aurait été
squattés bien avant ça on allait de
squat en squat
oui donc lui même si j'aimerais larudee
qu'avait par un occupant à titre
permanent elle est en permanence quoi
nous mais par des gens différents mais à
la fin la france et le mali ont visité
c'est évident lola mesures réalisées
dont des français jean babilée la
journée
mais j'ai visité trois fois la maison y
avait personne à chaque fois il y avait
un matelas par terre je sais pas il faut
des il faut des meubles il faudra
comment il y avait toute une famille et
il faut que les niveaux qu'elle m'a
chose toutefois est ce que est ce que
c'est parce qu'il est possible que les
agents immobiliers disent aux gens de
sortir pendant qu'ils font et va durer
ce que c'est possible non non non
cci ne serait pas sorti les pas de
meubles
avec les finitions et c'est bizarre
qu'il ait pu visiter à l'ancien la
famille n'était pas de
la glnf aux lacunes hier qui manque dans
dans le dans ce texte de vente par
exemple ce qu'il aurait pu demander
monsieur alors monsieur je vais vous
dire les squatteurs c'est épouvantable
en est en guerre contre eux déclarent et
je comprends votre douleur en revanche
moi je vous dis en face vous étiez
forcément au courant donc il faut en
subir les conséquences
donc bien sûr
vous êtes sur wii avant la vie il est
forcément pour les occasionnels mais ces
histoires y insérant épouvantable et je
suis d'accord avec nous mais ils
pensaient que c'était un squat moins
important
il savait tu pourras tu vas voir et tu
te poses la question à savoir ne pas te
donne pas les clefs et après les guerres
et non mais exactement ces infortunés
genre que le squat était moins important
mais en aucun cas vous sortez de chez le
notaire sans les clés voilà vous dit
rien ça n'existe pas vraiment ça
n'existe pas et même le squatteur quand
il dit qu'il a acheté la baraque 120000
euros je crois il a dit non
liquides c'est impossible
notre ère et accepter la maison
et
jamais pourquoi vous êtes sûr bernard
montiel que laurent le savez pourquoi
mais parce que c'est un acte de vente
quand on achète une baraque tout ça est
bien précisé ou alors vraiment le leur
la question que vous saviez qu'elle
était quoi squatter mais pas à ce point
là vous savez que c'était une maison qui
était souvent squatté vous êtes dit je
vais je vais qu'une fois que je vais
arriver ça va pas ils vont partir et je
vais pouvoir c'est ça je me suis dit si
je fais comme lors de la visite j'arrive
ya personne je m'installe dedans et
c'est fini parce qu'en général c'est
l'acte de vente est bien fait on sait
marquer de danse et ça les infos lacunes
hier que je disais qu'il manquait dans
cet accident de petits délits jugement
dit attendez le rempart dont on dit
simplement connaissent un taux la punir
sa soeur il n'y a qu'une à dire qu'il
manquait des choses c'est à dire que la
lumière non sa mère lacunes hier
quelques j'ai des lacunes hier à
lacunaire et et donc non on essaie de
savoir ça fait rien tout est normal que
je suis ressorti
à lancer de savoir donc il est marqué
qu'en même temps les gens étaient là
dans le dans l'établissement fait dans
cette maison etc d'eau doit-elle à
cotiser dans l'acte de vente et ça y est
pas victime accueillir la promesse oui
mais dans l'acte de vente c'est écrit
que c'est occupé de personnes faut quand
même comprendre que et il a rien commis
d'illégal mais nous devons bien clair en
fait partie de l'axé vente enfin si
l'option de vente non c'est pas la
première ça sérieusement tu liras la
baie de menton de pages il doit pas
ajouter comme beaucoup de se faire
justice lui-même et d'aller manu
militari en alors justement oui
justement parce que ces endroits
dirigeants impliqués vendredi dernier au
matin après votre passage donc interdit
soit on apprend que les squatteurs ont
quitté le pavillon sous la pression la
veille au soir les squatteurs ont été
agressés alors qu'ils préparaient leurs
affaires pour quitter le pavillon
environ 10 personnes cagoulées sont
arrivés avant de frapper des adultes de
la famille et de les asperger de gaz
lacrymogène ce véhicule a été également
dégradée c'est quoi cette histoire
gilles oui laurent là aussi ça paraît
très bras au moment où vous médiatiser
la faire
de gens avec des cagoules détruit la
voiture des squatteurs alors qu'ils sont
en train de partir abymes leur véhicule
du gaz lacrymogène alors que c'est quand
même une famille des squatteurs ok mais
une famille à une plusieurs enfants est
notre ambassade exactement même moment
et vous dites après abba si j'avais su
je l'aurais dit pas le faire parce
qu'ils nuisent à mes intérêts comment
voulez vous leur en croit ce que vous
n'étiez pas au courant que des gens
allaient pousser ces squatters à partir
très vite ce excusez moi mais là c'est
impossible pour nous de vous croire
alors alors alors on va laisser l'aurait
pris non c'est pas le bas là je sais
même pas quoi vous répondre là vous dit
en gros que j'étais au courant là que
qu'ils allaient qui les à les agresser à
savoir
la section g il va les actes et
non c'est pas lui c'est justement ce
qu'on a dit si l'empathie et non
mercredi giljura l'intérêt de laurent
mais oui
des agressés
par les personnes quotas agressé mais
évidemment comment peut-on imaginer qu
est ce qu il aurait gagné après des
semaines de bataille il s'en va bien sûr
il va les agresser et se tirer dans le
pied c'est quand mon mariage
et puis voilà je suis donc
vraiment ce serait une énorme connerie
que vous voyez que la la faire se
décanter bah oui franchement alors oui
non mais c'est le monde à l'envers en
fait on est en train de faire de laurent
un coup bas alors c'est une victime
c'est quelqu'un moi je regarde mon
reportage du du parisien qui a travaillé
dur c'était son rêve des propriétaires
peut-être qui s'y connaît pas en
immobilier ils achètent une maison en
dessous du prix du marché effectivement
est en fait c'est de sa faute orks et
des squatteurs qui qui qui
sait qu'ils voulaient c'est celui qui
fait son boulot pour la maison qui me
plaisait pas et
qui habite dedans alors il est expliqué
c'est pareil quand tu achètes une maison
et que tu sais qu'à des squats et est
plus une victime est au courant ça ne
veut pas dire attends ça veut pas dire
que il est content et qui pensait qu'il
allait rentrer plus vite et c'est un ça
ça veut pas dire ça mais pardon dans
tous les grands
victimes quand moi j'achète un immeuble
qui est squatté et que je prévois de le
remettre à louer en six mois et qu'en
fin de compte ça prend deux ans j'ai
pris mon risque mon risque c'est de le
sous payés mais en train de fois et je
veux pas être si un choix je fais rien
que ça veut dire cette date photo
martial voilà c'est passé tout ça mais
c'est de choisir a dénoncé pas la
victime s'est passé non des travaux
énormes à faire c'est
sympa dame parle pas d'une ville à vélo
toute façon le prix est pas parce qu ils
vont tous travaux à faire laurent juste
dit nous la vérité dans le truc dans
dans l'acte de vente us avec il était
squatté je savais que tu l'avais payé
moins cher pour ça mais tu savais pas
que c'était un squat permanence et ça
c'est ça c'est ça que je dis depuis le
début en pleine journée sens que j'ai
depuis le début j'ai précisé qu'il y
avait toujours un rien eu un match la
hausse donc tu t'es pas imaginer
pourquoi tu t'es dit que tu avais payé
cette maison beaucoup moins cher pour ça
bah ça et j'étais dans la maison qu'elle
est dans un sale état d'accord il faut
faire il faut faire l'isolation il ya
une chaîne la chaudière a changé c'est
au fioul il faut faire l'assainissement
l'électricité n'est pas aux normes là il
ya de l'amiante la plomberie j'ai tout à
refaire dans la maison mais combien est
passé entre le moment où vous avez
visité la maison il y avait juste un mac
là et vous êtes bon bah ça doit être un
squatteur ou des petits jeunes de temps
en temps et quand vous y êtes revenu et
qu'il y avait vraiment le chien les
rideaux et les meubles en septembre mais
c'est passé huit mois huit mois de juin
neuf mois et pendant ces huit mois là
vous êtes jamais retourné non ah bon
vous êtes avec tous les travaux car et
envoyer quelqu'un pour vérifier les
travaux ne serait ce que pour l'équipe
ne te sens pas venir des professionnels
immobiliers nous on en maths en asie
travaux à faire tu dois envoyer
quelqu'un pour faire un devis tu dis il
ya la chaudière a le truc donc toi mai
2002 travaux ou 200 milles c'est pareil
mais j'étais obligé d'envoyer quelqu'un
paye un prix le prix me convient je sais
que j'ai des travaux à faire le bris
quand j'aurai la même venir si tuer des
gens ils vont venir problème je ne peux
pas le prix le prix ne peux pas te
convenir si tu connais pas le prix des
travaux regarde toi tu achète une maison
140 c'est pas pareil s'il ya 100 ou 200
travaux c'est danser dans une villa
je suis un professionnel de l'immobilier
alors c'est soit tu sais en un coup
d'oeil qu'on arrive à passer
disent que c'est dit laurent la maison
elle coûte normalement 240000 euros il a
payé 140 il s'est dit on au maximum au
maximum et j'aurai 50 milles de travaux
au max donc elle va me revenir 190
j'aurais quand même fait une norme à
faire puisque je la paye 50 mille euros
de deux mois que c'est une série mais
pendant huit mois il va pas l'avoir ça
m'intéresse pas il n'y voit pas ce qu
est ce qui se passe dans cette maison là
ça se précise les baisers la l1 crédit
pour 25 ans il a bataillé pour avoir son
crédit on va pas voir les maisons dix
fois avant d acheter des partisans si si
si non mais alors papa d'un bien mais si
sondages et qui achètent une maison tout
du prix du marché il ya huit mois et qui
veut pas savoir combien il va avoir de
viterra zone turf il n'existe pas de
visiter il ya sept mois bill acheté
récemment mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'il aurait pu se faire se faire
justice je voudrais juste dire parce que
c'est important si qu'en 2014 est un
délit qui est sorti qui s'appelle délit
d' expulsion illégale en fait lorsque
l'année ont squatté lorsqu'on exploiter
et qu'on va sortir les occupants ce papa
de violences l'une allemand là c'est
clair mais on les sort eh bien on est
condamné à trois ans de prison 30 mille
euros damende il aurait pu tricher ils
sont aujourd'hui on vient lui faire un
procès en disant oui mais tu as profité
sellafield a le droit alors après qu'on
dise qu a manqué aux médias on expliquer
le contexte en même temps mais en vrai
moi je veux dire l'histoire pour moi
elle est tout à fait simple et je pense
que c'est ce que j'ai essayé j'ai un
instant laurent icdi je vais faire une
très belle affaire immobilière et je
vais voilà cent quarante mille euros
c'est incroyable pour cette mission ça
vaut 100 milles de plus je vois là je
vais prendre le risque des squatteurs
temps il s'est dit voilà au pire des cas
je verrai je vais voir comment je vais
je veux savoir marcher avec ça mais la
maison au pire du pire elle va me coûter
190 mille euros je vais faire une
économie de 50 mille euros et je pense
laurent que tu savais voilà je sais pas
s'ils savaient qu'ils avaient des six
avait des squatteurs permanent mais tu
nous as dit que tu pensais qu'ils
avaient des squatters voilà ce que
l'émission était la maison était
énormément squatté mais tu t'es dit je
vais faire un coup tu t'es dit je prends
un risque mais je fais un coup c'est ça
en fait l'histoire en vraie histoire
elle est là et je crée je comprends tout
à fait sages ce curseur vers l'est c'est
un choix et ses minots 1 c'est une
spéculation du déni ben voila moi je
vais je vais tenter le coup et voilà que
non mais non c'est ça je pense un peu
c'est beaucoup c'est
un peu ça mais on lui reproche d'avoir
menti alors qu'en fait effectivement il
se pensait à des squatters occasionnels
c'est pas la même chose qu'à une maison
installée ou quoi qu'il arrive il peut
pas que j'ai vu l'émission il nous a
fait une sérieuse elle est partie dans
la tente un coup à 140 milles si je
tends pas quoi 140000 je vais sortir moi
tu vas voir de trois potes ils ont
dégagé vite fait bien fait il avait
regardé sourit il a lu que ça c'est
compliqué et quand ça s'est compliqué il
a vu que la famille à voulait pas bouger
le derrière et on est venu lundi il
était à 10 aussi l'appeler ses copains
j'ai appelé mes copains ça fait 1-1
siphonnage pas possible ça je suis frais
après non mais ce qui s'est passé après
c'est qu'il a alerté les médias si tu
tentes un truc à 140 milles va jusqu'au
bout mais les repas les médias pour ça
j'attends du
notaire sans excès il a perpétué et
s'est dit moi je vais jouer tout n'est
qu'argent effet d'affaires des ajouté
laurent voilà vous aurais préféré quoi
en gros que j'ai je la paye 250 je suis
dans le dos au fond du gouffre et que tu
as deux doigts de me préférait les
arrange bien parce que j'aurais préféré
avec ta femme une maison à 140 milles en
dessous du marché était chez le notaire
il donne pas les clefs tu signes pas moi
je n'achète pas une voiture s'il est
qu'ils me donnent arrêté
a désormais deux donc c'est monsieur qui
est sur le banc des accusés mais c'est
lui jamais la vérité c'est qu'il
agissait maison ils le savaient
certainement icdi faut que je fasse en
sorte de les expulser et comme il est
malin et qu'il a dit là j'y arrive pas
et comment je fais je vais appeler les
médias et il a bien mais
il
n'était pas obligé de dire on ne savait
pas mais attendez arrêté on peut
attendre l affaire s'étonne de
ça vous non
maintenant on regarde il a fait une
maison en dessous du prix du marché
personne
il savait qu'elle est et ce quoi c est
ce que je crois que personne ne lui en
veux de sakho qui jouent le jeu des
médias mais là on veut bien sûr s'il a
bien fait mais là le seul au procès
c'est sur le fait que quand il est venu
avec sa femme il a ému toute la france
et
je suis d'accord mais tu écoutes le
sortir quand est ce qu on a vu
l'émission à la fin on sait pas dit oui
oui il savait qu'elle était squatté et
puis ça prend plus de temps et
s'insurgent à la différence
va se faire bien jeu il a joué je vais
alors je pense que des actes comme ça
mais
ça je suis désolé c'est vrai problème de
squats vous avez complètement
discréditée bon on est comme gérald
darmanin a fait activer les choses mais
c'est sa maison
mais
j'étais la cgt ont su gérer sa
lumière le problème
laurent maintenant aujourd'hui est ce
que tu es dans ta maison c'est à lui
swiss as et c'est bon c'est un vieux
tu vas faire les travaux commencés ouais
t'as commencé les travaux
ça y est t'es tranquille je suis
tranquille à lormont coutume à revendre
la vérité est ce que je lis toi et je te
le dis la fin je suis servi des médias
je t'ai dis bah je vais faire un combat
non mais c'est vrai il s'est dit gêné sa
maison était vraiment squatter s'est dit
je vais me servir des médias pour faire
c'était peut-être son plan oui
aujourd'hui il a récupéré sa barbe et il
a payé sa maison
c'est chaud
et dj fresh n'aurait pas été un problème
n'est pas invité
j'ai eu à baisser moins cher mais tu as
raison leur est pas du tout
mais voilà il a joué au mieux à travers
passés tous ceux qui sont squattés
samyang en lumière ce qu'ils font